bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic
la formation du système solaire nous
sommes quatre milliards et demi d'années
dans le passé à cette époque très
lointaine notre planète la terre et même
notre étoile le soleil n'existe pas
encore au fin fond d'une galaxie qu'on
appelle la voie lactée
un vaste nuage de gaz et de poussières
est en train de se modifier dans ce
nuage de matière
suite à des perturbations venus de
l'extérieur les particules se déplace et
certaines zones se densifie à cause de
leur attraction gravitationnelle ces
zones plus massive que les autres vont
attirer la matière environnante vers
elle de cette façon le nuage est en
train de s'effondrer lentement sur lui
même
[Musique]
en se contractant le centre du nuage
devient de plus en plus dense et à cause
des chocs entre les particules sa
température augmente tandis qu'ils se
mettent à tourner de plus en plus vite
en son coeur
là où presque toute la matière du nuage
s'est concentrée la pression et la
température deviennent si intense
qu'elle entraîne l'apparition d'un
embryon des toiles c'est le soleil
l'astre central du système solaire qui
vient de naître
cela dit n'est pas encore stable et
continue toujours de s'effondrer sous
l'action de son propre poids on dit que
le soleil n'est pour l'instant qu'une
protoétoile il faudra attendre encore
quelques dizaines de millions d'années
avant que sa pression interne ne
devienne assez élevé pour lui permettre
de se stabiliser
pendant ce temps le peu de matière qui
reste dans le nuage est en train de
s'aplatir autour de son axe de rotation
à cause des différentes forces de
gravité de l'effet centrifuge et des
collisions entre les particules qui
tendent à ramener la matière sur un même
plan à l'intérieur de ce disque à force
d'entrer en collision
les poussières du rocher de glace
commence à s'agréger de sorte à former
des amas de matière qui vont devenir de
plus en plus gros en fonction de leurs
distances au soleil la composition de
ces fragments de matière n'est pas la
même à proximité de la protoétoile la
température est trop élevée pour que les
composés léger comme l'eau ou le méthane
puissent se condenser sous leur forme
solide dans cette zone les amas de
matière vont donc se former à partir des
quelques éléments restés solides
principalement des roches et des métaux
al'inverse à l'extérieur du disque la
température est assez faible pour que
tous ces matériaux légers puisse rester
sous leur forme solide
les amas vont donc pouvoir grossir
davantage dans cette zone car il dispose
de toute cette matière supplémentaire
sous forme de glace
[Musique]
en devenant de plus en plus massifs ces
immenses noyau de matières vont alors se
mettre à attirer par la gravitation une
grande quantité d'hydrogène et d'hélium
présent sous forme de gaz
ces gaz qui composaient à l'origine une
partie du nuage ont été repoussée
jusqu'ici par les vents très puissants
que génère le soleil au bout de quelques
millions d'années seulement
c'est immense boule de matières se
stabilise et terminent leur croissance
on les appelle planète gazeuse à savoir
jupiter saturne uranus et neptune à
proximité du soleil les amas de roches
et de métaux forme désormais de grandes
boucles de matière au cours des
prochains millions d'années ils ne vont
cesser d'entrer en collision les uns
avec les autres
jusqu'à ne laissait plus que quelques
corps massif en orbite autour du soleil
[Musique]
ce sont les planètes rocheuses à savoir
mercure vénus la terre et mars
[Musique]
enfin la matière restantes qui n'a pas
réussi à s'agréger va former les
astéroïdes et les comètes qui orbitent
encore aujourd'hui autour du soleil à
l'échelle de l'univers
notre système solaire s'est formé très
rapidement en quelques millions d'années
seulement les lois de la physique donne
naissance à une nouvelle étoile entouré
de planètes et d'une multitude d'autres
corps célestes
cela dit dans l'univers tout se
transforme
et le système solaire ne va pas durer
indéfiniment d'ici environ 5 milliards
d'années le soleil aura consommé tout
son carburant et il va alors s'éteindre
lentement emportant avec lui tous les
objets qui l'entourent
[Musique]